ceci dit ça il parle comme ça tout le
temps comme si le canada est un leader
en matière d'environnement essayez pas
de changer l'histoire maintenant
monsieur trudeau et j'écoutais le débat
en anglais vous disiez que c'est un win
win win et l'impact du niqab sur
l'économie
que de prises de bec d'échangés
enflammés et acrimonieux au cours des
deux dernières semaines
et bien la saison des débats est
finalement terminée ce qui permettra aux
chefs d'entamer la dernière ligne droite
de la campagne
qu'est ce qui change à partir de
maintenant comment les chefs doivent
t'ils s'ajuster et bien j'en discute
avec nos stratèges robert asselin du
parti libéral vous êtes à toronto
aujourd'hui catherine loubier du parti
conservateur à ottawa
dominique vallières du bloc québécois
vous êtes à montréal et pour nos
auditeurs pour des raisons techniques on
peut pas rejoindre car le valais pardon
car le bélanger aujourd'hui du npd et
donc on a évité avec nous rebecca
blaikie présidente du npd donc bon
dimanche à vous quatre
bonjour bonjour roberge commenceraient
avec vous quatre des bancs de semaine on
n'avait pas vu ça en campagne électorale
avant quel bilan vous andré si ce qui
est une bonne formule finalement cette
saison des débats oui je pense était
utile parce que des débats ça sert
surtout à démontrer les contrastes entre
les chefs je pense que le maintenant
après quatre débats légende bonne
appréciation de où se situent les chefs
sur les quinze ans je donc c'est un rôle
d'éducation qui est important nous des
plateformes de ce qu'on propose
moi ce que je déplore évidemment c'est
que en anglais ait pas eu de débat de
vrais débats nationaux largement
diffusés avec le consortium entre autres
comme dieu en france est alors je pense
que beaucoup de cas radier
malheureusement qui n'ont pas eu la
chance d'entendre les chefs donc en
anglais à cause du fait que globez maire
des membres qui étaient débattus sont
plus restreints en termes d'audience
alors je pense que c'est dommage à ce
niveau là oui parce que catherine mois
on a les codes des coupes parents du
débat du consortium qui en français
seulement ont rejoint plus de 800 mille
auditeurs plus 2 millions quand on
inclut les chaînes spécialisées
anglophone tva aussi au job board
important que des côtes mais qu'on les
regarde ces débats anglais c'est quoi 2
300 mille personnes est ce que peut un
déséquilibre pour les électeurs
canadiens
non je pense les électeurs canadiens ont
eu cinq débats le plus grand nombre de
débats de l'histoire du canada et donc
je pense que c'est suffisant pour eux il
faudrait avoir avec les électeurs
directement mais pour découvrir un peu
la personnalité des chefs
surtout dans le cas de monsieur
de monsieur mal que bien évidemment et
monsieur trudeau parce que bon ils sont
ils en sont à leur premier premier débat
comme avec la proposition d'être chef et
d'être élu premier ministre et donc
c'est c'est une occasion pour eux
d'avoir des face-à-face intéressant qui
fait sortir leurs personnalités et leurs
intentions et leurs programmes et ce
qu'ils vont mettre de l'avant des coupes
importantes s qui propose l'équilibré
budgétaire est ce qu'ils vont être
capables de deux d'avoir des
conversations sérieuses avec des leaders
d'autres grands pays alors je pense les
électeurs on en ont eu beaucoup pour
leur argent
comment dit rebecca le npd certains ont
déjà reproché ou npd d'avoir un peu joué
le jeu des conservateurs dans ces
tractations sur les débats pour vous
c'est un bon pari que les débats en
anglais soient pas diffusés sur les
grandes chaînes de télévision mais garde
moi je pense que c'est vrai que les deux
débats en français on a vu beaucoup plus
de profondeur sur les questions c'est
dommage qu'on n'a pas aller dans ce même
profondeur en anglais mais quand même
pour ceux qui ont écouté ils y ont vu
clairement
tonia pu se montrer solide
d'expérimenter mai
garde il faut que le premier né soit là
c'est important si on peut battre le
premier ministre qui soit présent au
débat moi je met le blâme dirais qu'au
premier ministre là dessus là mais
j'espère aussi que des canadiens d'ici
les dernières deux semaines ils vont
aller chercher ces débats les écouter si
l'on peut encore faire mais on vers je
sais que jeudi soir aux cols
c'était un très bon débat je pense que
tous les chefs ont bien performé et
comment de mon avis surtout surtout tom
nominés que oui on sente docteur
dominique pour vous le bloc québécois
hugues la misère à s'imposer dans le
début de la campagne
est ce que vous voyez ces débats comme
un point tournant a écouté les débats
c'est toujours un moment où est ce que
les chefs peuvent au delà des contrastes
hanté différents chefs peuvent
s'adresser de personne à personne de
caractère avec avec les électeurs alors
nous c'est sûr que d'avoir va monsieur
duceppe deux fois pendant deux heures
sans filtre qui s'adressent ces sublimes
ben ça va pas sauver les meubles mais ça
nous a donné c'est monsieur duceppe a
l'habitude de bien faire former dans les
débats nous aussi on aurait pris un
débat en anglais
cependant on l'est on laisse à chaque
cas chaque organisateur le loisir
d'invités qu'ils veulent on en aurait
pris un autre mais c'est pas c'est pas
grave on a bien fait avec deux mais non
on rend la dernière fois je pense qu'on
peut dire de la campagne électorale ça
va changer l'europe pour les bénéfices
de nos auditeurs on le fait des petits
calculs
jusqu'ici depuis donc le début du mois
d'août les chefs les quatre ont visité
157 circonscriptions sur 338 donc encore
une bonne partie du pays on peut dire
qu'il ya pas été explorées la plus
visitée c'est vous donne en mille
spectateurs fort york visité 12 fois
roberge commencera avec vous c'est votre
chef est celui qui sait la
circonscription dans laquelle il est
allé le plus souvent est ce que
à partir de maintenant comment on
choisit les circonscriptions où on va
faire campagne c'est très simple on va
nous on pense qu'on peut faire des gains
et dans notre cas il ya beaucoup de
gains possibles en ontario mais en a
partout dans le pays ont nettement en
eau dans l'ouest y en a au québec dans
les maritimes
on a beaucoup de gains aussi possible
alors c'est d'aller dans les comtés où
la lutte est chaude où la présence du
chef peut faire vraiment différence et
comme on dit en bon français elle est
close et le dire allez allez dire aux
gens que le changement c'est nous qui
l'incarnons et qu'on est prêt à
gouverner le 19 à partir du 19 octobre
catherine vous votre chef parmi les
circonscriptions où l'italie le plus
souvent lieu à beaucoup allé deux fois
chaque endroit ce que c'est presque une
stratégie volontaire du parti
conservateur était lui aussi deux fois à
québec
je vous demanderai la majorité des
électeurs les voit pas les chefs quand
ils viennent dans leur circonscription
le cediv rallye c'est très c'est quand
même assez contrôlé peu importe la
formule
qu'est ce que ça change qui se déplace
quelque part si rencontre pas vraiment
les électeurs du talent et il est allé
plus que deux fois québec qui est allé
je pense qu'on est rendu à vue deux fois
au québec et à québec quatre ou cinq
fois ce que ça change en fait parfois on
veut aller à la rencontre de nos
partisans des bénévoles des centaines et
centaines de bénévoles comme on l'a fait
récemment à québec et c'est la priorité
quand on se déplace parfois l'agenda
permet pas de faire plus que qu'un arrêt
de ce genre là mais c'est aussi de là la
rencontre directement des électeurs que
ce soit en leur parlant en faisant des
entrevues radio des entrevues plus local
si on peut dire ou en visitant un
commerce ou un autre mais c'est toujours
le même message
on veut entendre ce qui préoccupe les
les électeurs directement dans chacune
des régions plus d'argent dans leurs
poches et coeur des cap sur l'économie
des budgets équilibrés et après ça on
ramène ça avec nous et on continue à la
fin de l'élection comme ça il reste deux
semaines en fait c'est beaucoup de
semaines mais on se demandait ce qu'il
faut garder le cap parce que notre
campagne va bien est ce qu'on doit faire
des mises au point où changer
complètement dans notre quote je pense
qu'on continue avec notre musique notre
message protéger l'économie
c'est rare qu'on voit un chef
un aveu d'échec pour quelques chefs que
ce soit que de changer de stratégie
complètement bébé quand j'irai avec vous
votre chef aujourd'hui fait c'est ce
mini rally se rencontrent à travers
l'ontario il commence à brentford va
finir dans l'essex près de windsor
est-ce qu'on rentre dans la phase où on
parle où on est vraiment dans les
rassemblements dans le partisan d'en
créer une vague plutôt que de parler
connus à partir de maintenant je pense
que oui c'est vrai ça me fait 6 réalise
aujourd'hui dans un territoire le sud
ouest de l'ontario ou qu'on espère faire
beaucoup de gains lors de l'élection
fait que c'est d'aller auprès des
électeurs on sait que sur le terrain ya
beaucoup de gens qui veulent rencontrer
tom que beaucoup d'énergie par rapport à
un au rallye donc c'est ce qui va faire
le tour un peu de toutes ces places là
pour respirer assuré que les gens sont
prêts à aller voter que le moment tom
garde sa place dans toutes les places
aux s'il faut se rappeler que nous ou
npd faut juste aller chercher une autre
trentaine de sièges pour pouvoir battre
stephen harper donc on sait qu'il ya au
moins une cinquantaine ou qu'on est bien
placé pour gagner fait qu'on est en
bonne position
comme c'est sûr qu'il va continuer à
faire le tour de toutes ces places là et
en espérant qu'elle 19 octobre on aura
le résultat qu'on veut dominer qu'est ce
qui change pour monsieur duceppe à
partir de maintenant lui que jusqu'ici
vous m'avez envoyé les chefs visiter
quoi 52 e circonscription et habite fils
de fer contre campagne dans une seule
province c'est plus facile mais en quoi
sont au rythme de campagne va changer
pour lui voler sa va complètement
changer c'est à dire qu'on commence à
faire campagne en avion désormais je
vous le donne à partir de vendredi la
vie pour la journée de vendredi on a
on a des rassemblements à montréal dans
charlevoix on s'en va ensuite à rimouski
à gaspé et à sept-îles
alors le rythme vraiment complètement
changé et puis nous c'est la marque de
commerce de monsieur duceppe
on finit toujours les campagnes presque
sans dormir à les rencontrer des gens
partout au québec
ça nous donne à nous beaucoup d'énergie
puis les militants aux autres aussi donc
c'est un bel échange qui se fait entre
entre entre eux et nous la fin des
campagnes robert ils pressent plus tard
mais on le moment où on dévoile les
plateformes l'ensemble du programme
classes une campagne aussi longue ça
compte autant qu'avant ça oui ça compte
je pense que les gens veulent avoir le
document
la plateforme qui résume l'ensemble des
engagements devant nous on est déjà
déposé notre cadre financier les gens
comprennent ce qu'on va faire au niveau
fiscal niveau financier mais avoir une
plateforme c'est important on a annoncé
la majorité d'à grande majorité de nos
engagements et je pense que cela car une
utilité mais à la fin de la campagne
c'est vraiment démontré le momentum dans
notre cas aujourd'hui on va avoir un des
plus grand rallye fait dans l'histoire
politique canadienne
alors c'est de montrer que dans le fond
on a le moment thomas dans le vent dans
les voiles et qu'on est prêts on se
dirige tranquillement mais sûrement la
raf la date fatidique du 19 octobre
c'est malheureusement tout le temps
qu'on a d'un coup trois heures je vous
promets je commençais avec vous la
semaine prochaine on rentre après la
saison des débats la saison des rallyes
donc je vous remercie d'avoir été avec
nous